right now we're in Gadsden Alabama it's
about an hour north from Birmingham this
is Roy Moore's hometown and this is the
mall that he was reportedly banned from
while trying to pick up underage girls
so we're gonna talk to some people
inside and find out what they think
about Roy morning
I don't know believe a word of anything
against it reason I don't believe it is
that he's been in the public eye for so
long and been in so many controversial
situations we're talking about years and
years why didn't all the sudden just pop
up I don't know whined and like I said
anybody in Washington DC and where else
tell us trying to tell us how to vote
down here we know the man and I think
he'd make good choices choices and you
know folks like myself with Bobby Mike I
came to Alabama to find out what people
here think about former Chief Justice
Roy Moore and the choices he's made in
his life how could a twice fired judge
with multiple sexual assault allegations
be voted into the US Senate what some
people said here surprised me I'm a
Democrat but I would I would still vote
for him I stand behind what he does and
as far as world war goes staying behind
you know his Christian beliefs and stuff
like that with my dad being a minister
and all of that it made sense that Roy
Moore would get the benefit of the doubt
in his home town you think that even
though he has all these allegations
against him that he has a chance of
winning yeah really yeah because this is
gas in Alabama but in a year that scene
so many powerful men resign or be fired
for sexual assault allegations
I wondered if people outside of Moores
home town would be more inclined to
believe the allegations this is
Woodstock a town in Bibb County just
outside of Birmingham Alabama America's
fourth blackest city but this County 76
percent white and in 2016 Trump won 77
percent of the vote here if they wanted
to do something they should have
before when he was running for things
and why after 40 years do you come
forward a lot of people say that women
sometimes when they do get you know
assaulted or what-have-you that it takes
them years to get the courage to come
forward one of them had the interview on
TV there weren't no tears in her eyes if
they had her mascara will run if they're
not true why would all these women be
saying this now who do you think would
be behind
I think it's doug jones and the
democrats but haven't the rumors been
around for years even when he is rumors
are there though those things exist
always you know until you're convicted
you're innocent you know just because
they're allegations made against you
doesn't make you guilty but with the
allegations piling up even some
Republicans have lost faith and more
usually how do you usually it's mainly
Republican mm-hmm I'm a woman so of
course you know you kind of lean towards
a certain way and whenever you know the
pain you have to there's got to be
something there no one's just gonna sit
there and make it up in tons of them
different once normally I don't talk
politics or religion but I know just
enough about everything that's been out
there that I know enough not to vote for
more because of the allegations
absolutely absolutely there's got to be
some truth to all of that not all of it
but some of it but it's just enough
remaining for a lot of people Moore's
image as a man of faith is enough to win
their vote an image built on his
decision to defy the law and install a
statue of the ten commandments at the
state courthouse it got him fired from
the Alabama Supreme Court but still wins
him a lot of respect today how many
people do you know would lose their job
over fighting for the Tim Commandments
why more it's because he stands up for
what he believes in he does what the
people
him in for his rights like the 10
commandments in everything I think he's
a good Christian man I take his word
before would work people in security my
Christian values are mine right and
that's for theirs but it has nothing to
do with running Alabama right you know
running Alabama is what can you do for
us even though her husband wouldn't talk
to us on camera he told us he's voting
for more because back in those days what
more is accused of was normal do you
think there are people who believe it
but who still might vote for him because
they just don't want Doug Jones to it I
gotta live with these people shouldn't
what you do matter more than what you
stand for whether he did it or whether
he did not do it
I like wait for what the man stands for
I like you know and it's tough it's
tough you know I'm not gonna do I don't
want to judge him what became clear to
me is that a lot of more supporters felt
that they had to vote for him because
the stakes are too high
an alternative even worse I don't wanna
know the Democrat Anini puppy power
and I just feel like that we need to go
the route the front leaving my believe
is a fair and honest man
that's that I don't want a Democrat in
office because we need his vote in
Washington because he stands with what
Trump is for whether it's his views on
race women's rights LGBT rights his
views that Muslims shouldn't serve in
government Roy Moore has a history of
hate you've got to get all the facts
you've got to look at it you got to look
at the time and usually you can look at
their face and if you got that feeling
then you know something's there when you
look at Roy Moore space what do you what
do you think I believe there's something
there whether it's all true or not but
even if there's one that that happened
to then it was still wrong but in a
deeply evangelical and racially
segregated State Moore's got a solid
block of voters rallying behind him the
question is will it be enough
hey it's Atman so if you liked this
video be sure to check out all the other
awesome documentaries and videos on this
channel and tell us what stories you
want us to cover and be sure to
subscribe to AJ Plus